تنتقل الروبوتات القاتلة بسرعة من
هوليوود إلى الواقع، وقد سلطت الوتيرة السريعة التي
تطورها الذكاء الاصطناعي على مدار العام الماضي
الضوء على
تطبيقاتها العسكرية القاتلة المحتملة، وبدون أي
معاهدات عالمية لوقفها،
قد يأتي Terminator في وقت أقرب مما
تعتقد
في القرن الحادي والعشرين.  في القرن سيتم
اختراع سلاح لا مثيل له،
سيكون هذا السلاح
متعدد الاستخدامات وغير قابل للتدمير،
لا يمكن التفكير فيه،
لا يمكن التورط في هذا،
لن نشعر بالشفقة لأننا
لم نصل إلى هذه المرحلة بعد، لكن البنتاغون
يتسابق حاليًا للخروج  أسطول من
الطائرات بدون طيار ذاتية القيادة يقال إن روسيا
تطور طوربيدًا نوويًا مستقلاً تحت الماء،
الروبوتات القاتلة قادمة،
هل هناك أي شيء يمكن أن يوقف
سباق تسلح عالمي واسع النطاق للذكاء الاصطناعي، دعونا
نحضر كريس رياتا، خبير الأمن السيبراني
في FCW الذي يغطي أعمال
التكنولوجيا الفيدرالية كريس  لقد شهدنا
هذا التقدم السريع في تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي
على مدار العام الماضي والذي قلب
كل الصناعات تقريبًا رأسًا على عقب. أريد أن أسألك
كيف يتم ذلك في الجيش،
هل نحن على الطريق إلى
الروبوتات القاتلة ذاتية التحكم التي تعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي،
نعم مرحبًا جون، انظر، إنها بالتأكيد
موضوع جاء في الوقت المناسب مع إصدار Chachi
PT وهذا الانهيار اليومي على ما يبدو من
منتجات الذكاء الاصطناعي الجديدة التي تصل إلى
السوق، أه الكثير من الناس يقولون أننا
الآن في العصر الذهبي للذكاء الاصطناعي،
لا أوافق على ذلك، أعتقد أننا في الفجر
الذكاء الاصطناعي أعني أن هذه التكنولوجيا الناشئة
في أيامها الأولى التي قالت إن
العالم بأكمله بالتأكيد في سباق للذكاء الاصطناعي
ربما ليس سباق تسلح للذكاء الاصطناعي
حتى الآن ولكن لجنة الأمن القومي الأمريكية
أه والمجتمع بشكل
عام يريد حقًا أن يكون كذلك  القادة في
هذا السباق أه ولكن يجب أن نرجع خطوة
إلى الوراء هنا لأن الحكومة الفيدرالية
كانت تبحث وتطور تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي
للدفاع عن الطاقة لسنوات أعني أنه
يمكنك إلقاء نظرة على برنامج Skyboard الخاص بالقوات الجوية
والذي يبدو مشابهًا بشكل مخيف
لبرنامج أه Terminators Skynet لكن  في الواقع،
إنها مجرد جهود ذلك الفرع العسكري
لإنشاء طائرة بدون طيار مستقلة تمامًا،
لديك برنامج mq-25 التابع للبحرية
مع شركة بوينغ، أعني ببساطة أن
الحكومة الفيدرالية تعمل بالفعل على
بناء تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي للأمن الدولي
والدفاع ولكن السؤال الحقيقي
هو ما إذا كان  المخاطر تفوق
الفوائد
حسنًا، دعنا نتحدث عن هذا بشكل صحيح لأنك
تعلم أنه من الواضح أن الطائرات بدون طيار أصبحت
عنصرًا أساسيًا في الجيش على مدى العقود القليلة الماضية
ولكننا نتحدث عن
الأسلحة المستقلة التي لا
يتحكم فيها أي بشر ولذا اسمحوا لي أن
أسألكم عن  على نطاق عالمي في الوقت الحالي، هل
هناك أي قيود في الوقت الحالي على
البنتاغون أو الدول الأخرى التي تستخدم
أسلحة مستقلة تعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي، هل نحن على
شفا سباق تسلح عالمي،
حسنًا، وبعبارة بسيطة هنا، من
الواضح أن الحكومة تقف وراء الكرة
عندما يتعلق الأمر  إشراف مسؤول على الذكاء الاصطناعي
ولكن كانت هناك بعض الدعوات
لإيقاف الذكاء الاصطناعي مؤقتًا لمدة ستة
أشهر تقريبًا في جميع أنحاء العالم للسماح
بالرقابة والتنظيم المناسبين
وربما حتى نوع من
هيئة دولية للبدء في
تنظيم أه تطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي أه
لكن هذا قال  عندما أسأل مصادري، التي
تعرفونها في مجتمع الأمن القومي،
ما الذي يبقيهم مستيقظين حقًا في الليل، فهو
ما سيحدث إذا توقفت الولايات المتحدة مؤقتًا
بينما يواصل بقية
العالم تطوير تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي الخاصة بهم،
وتقنيات الدفاع وغيرها من أنواع
المبادرات
أعني أنك تعلم أنني لا أعتقد أن أي شخص
يختلف على أن الذكاء الاصطناعي ينطوي على مخاطر محتملة
خاصة في ساحة المعركة، لذا
أصدرت وزارة الدفاع العام الماضي
استراتيجية الذكاء الاصطناعي المسؤولة ومسار التنفيذ، إنها
هذه الوثيقة المكونة من 47 صفحة والتي تحدد بعض
أفضل الممارسات حول أشياء مثل
الحوكمة تطوير ثقة Warfighter
وإنشاء نظام بيئي مسؤول للذكاء الاصطناعي،
ولكن عندما يتعلق الأمر بهذه الدعوات للتوقف
مؤقتًا عن تطورات الذكاء الاصطناعي للسماح
بإنشاء لوائح
ورقابة مناسبة محليًا،
يقول مسؤولو وزارة الدفاع في الخارج إنه
ليس هناك هذا النوع من الوقت ل
حسنًا، حسنًا في هذه النقطة، لدينا مقطع
هنا كما ذكرت أه الأسبوع الماضي
خرج مسؤول في البنتاغون وقال إن
إيقاف التوقف لمدة ستة أشهر كما
ذكرت هي فكرة سيئة وقد
ناقش البعض وقفة لمدة ستة أشهر،
وأنا شخصيًا  لا تؤيد
ذلك لأنه إذا توقفنا عن التخمين من الذي
لن يوقف الخصوم المحتملين
في الخارج،
حسنًا، الخصوم المحتملون في الخارج،
أعني أنه يلمح إلى وجود سباق تسلح هذا،
فلن تتمكن الولايات المتحدة من التوقف عن تطوير
الذكاء الاصطناعي لأننا نحتاجه لأسلحتها،
فماذا تفعل؟  أعتقد أن هذا المقطع وهذا
الإعلان يخبرانك بكيفية
رؤية البنتاغون للذكاء الاصطناعي في الوقت الحالي،
هذا صحيح، هذا هو
كبير مسؤولي المعلومات في وزارة الدفاع جون شيرمان،
وهم يقترحون أن التوقف المؤقت سيكون
في الأساس غير واقعي تمامًا
للتنفيذ في جميع أنحاء العالم مما يسمح
لخصوم مثل الصين وروسيا
وكوريا الشمالية لمواصلة متابعة مبادرات الذكاء الاصطناعي، كما
تعلمون، ولكن من ناحية أخرى،
يحذر العديد من الخبراء أيضًا من أن
الذكاء الاصطناعي غير المنظم يشكل مخاطر كبيرة على الأمن القومي
الأجنبي.